good morning believe nation today's
message is do the best you can over to
you BB King well practice is something
that we think is something you should do
daily anyway because i'm lazy now don't
but generally you you kind of think for
example i know that the north sea jazz
festival people used to hear in various
types of music so when i come out i try
to do the best that I can do of my kind
of music this is a really important
message because BB king was a blues
player and he had to play it a lot of
non blues events and that forced him to
be the best that he could be it force
him to bring out the best in himself
because it was plain to a non converted
audience already and I've had to do this
on my channel and on youtube where I've
been a guest on a makeup and beauty
channel I've been a guest on a dating
and relationships channel sharing my
belief message and I had to work harder
to impress because I'm not dealing with
entrepreneurs and they've never met me
before and so I find that helped me
raise my game and make me the best that
I can be the other thing that I find
really helpful and this came from my
agent who's really kind of pounded into
my head is try to raise the stakes try
to make it more important and that
drives you to create the best work that
you can and so the ways that I do it are
if I am for example writing the
newsletter oh I will imagine that
somebody I respect is going to read it
so imagine like Tony Robbins is going to
be reading my newsletter and so it makes
me want to write it a little bit better
than just sitting there at the office
right in the newsletter when somebody
asks a question of me and I make a video
reply for them I try to imagine like
this is a life-or-death situation like
they on the edge of a bridge they're
about to jump over and my answer this
video that I'm making is the last thing
that they are going to see before they
make this really important decision that
increases the stakes right that makes it
more important that makes
we have to really cement my point and
bring it home to have an impact on them
and so I find that when I force myself
to be better when I force myself to go
beyond what I'm my usual level and like
really push it it creates a much better
and end product and result and
experience and I'm grateful to look for
those opportunities and so my question
of the day for you today is how do you
bring out the best in yourself you know
there are days that you float how do you
bring out the best in yourself on some
of those days we really have to deliver
I'm really curious leave in the comments
below on your join the discussion thank
you guys so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events presser